foreign
it's Naz Perez and welcome to the Rotten
Tomatoes binge guide boy do we have a
doozy for you today because we're gonna
bring you some very strong binge options
based on Wednesday and we're not talking
about hump day or the day after Taco
Tuesday we're talking about the hit new
series on Netflix that is people excited
about an Addams Family franchise that
has been around since the 1930s in this
revival Jenna Ortega stars as a
character Wednesday who while attending
Nevermore Academy is attempting to
master her psychic ability stop a
killing spree and work on solving a 25
year old mystery about her parents no
big deal the series is executive
produced by Tim Burton who also directed
half the episodes in the first season
now he notoriously passed on directing
the 1991 film and he once had a
stop-motion animation Adams Family
project in the works that actually never
materialized so here we are and while
Jenna is what critics and fans really
seem to love most about the show fans
have been buzzing about the supporting
casts as well but names like Catherine
Zeta Jones Gwendolyn Christie Fred
Armisen and of course course the one and
only Christina Ricci who previously
played Wednesday in the 90s movies
Nevermore was created as a safe haven
for our children
to learn and to grow no matter who or
what they are
should we meet your new roommate are you
feeling okay you look a little pale
please excuse Wednesday she's allergic
to color oh well what happens to you
I break out into hives and then the
flesh peels off my bones those are all
the reasons why we love Wednesday but
now here are five more shows that we
could all love together too
[Music]
starting with our brand new pick the
Winchesters for you folks that like your
Supernatural stuff in series form this
one is perfect as it is a prequel series
to the long-running CW staple
Supernatural in fact that show star
Jensen Ackles AKA Dean Winchester
narrates this one which is set in the
1970s and tells the love story of how
Dean's parents John Winchester and Mary
Campbell first met relative newcomer
Drake Roger SARS as John who returns
home from Vietnam and starts a new
mission to learn more about his father's
past that's when he crosses paths with a
19 year old Demon Hunter named Mary and
she's actually played by Meg Donnelly
from Disney's zombie movies now the
first season of the show has been a hit
with CW fans and is impressively
hovering around 100 fresh on the Tomato
Meter that's huge one top RT critic
Karama horn from the rap said the
Winchester's is off to a quote very
creative start while Jolly Herman from
Common Sense Media said that while it
may be gory and scary if the formula
continues it's quote bound to be a
proper recipe for fun team viewing in
real life scariness however shake-ups at
the CW have put a second season of this
show in some doubt but you let us worry
about that kind of stuff and we'll keep
you posted in the meantime you can start
watching all episodes of the first
season in just under 10 hours and at
that point you know you're gonna go
binge Supernatural too but with 15
seasons of that so good luck
how did you find me
that's what I do or what I did in the
Marines
anyway you are not the only person that
I found
Witnesses saw black smoke but there were
no signs of fire on the premises Aiden
Monroe owner of a rare Bookstore in
Lubbock Texas has been missing since
last evening
come on that's got to be the 80 you're
looking for right God said he was in
Lubbock great let's get down there
I feel like a dog with a bone
and coffee
come on Texas awaits I told you I'm
trying to protect you next up is our
certified Fresh Pick chilling Adventures
of Sabrina now this Netflix show is
based on the Archie comic book series of
the same name and it is four fresh
Seasons two of them are certified fresh
inspired by Slow Burn horror films like
the Exorcist and Rosemary's Baby this
show imagines the origins and Adventures
of Sabrina the Teenage Witch as a dark
coming-of-age stories and it stars
Kiernan shipka as Sabrina shipka came
into the project already known for her
role on Mad Men but this Series has
certainly brought her a bigger and
different kind of audience chilling
Adventures of Sabrina was originally in
development at the CW and it was
intended to be a companion series to
Riverdale which shipka ultimately did
appear on after this one was canceled
speaking of which Netflix canceled the
series in part because of the kova 19
pandemic in July of 2020 despite its
continued success come on people there
was at least a comic book series
continuation that began publication in
October of 2021 that's worth looking
into and critics say this delightfully
can't be Iran provides the perfect
showcase for shipka's Magical talent and
is a deliciously hellish Thrill Ride
from start to finish and despite what
many consider to be too soon of an
ending critics say that the final season
does hit quote enough emotional highs to
serve as a fitting farewell and as we
say farewell to this show I can tell you
that it will take you about 36 hours to
binge on Netflix and naturally it does
come with a holiday special so I'm in
the middle of getting this club started
at school club what kind of Club women
protecting women you know sort of like a
coffin
anyway I was wondering if we could maybe
possibly postpone my baptism a little
bit postpone it oh Sabrina you cannot
postpone your 16th birthday especially
not when it falls on the eclipsing of a
Blood Moon which only occurs once every
66 years
it's just about a club taking us back 60
years or so for our throwback pick is
the original Addams Family series now
this classic ran for two seasons
starting in 1964. and is based on
Charles Adams as New York cartoons that
began in 1938 but what this 30-minute
black and white show did was take the
unnamed characters from that comic strip
and give them backstories and names and
put them in a household setting this
Macabre family with supernatural
abilities includes Gomez Adams the
enthusiastic patriarch played by John
Aston and his refined wife Morticia
played by Carolyn Jones now they're
surrounded by two odd kids Pugsley and
Wednesday plus other family members a
giant butler named Lurch and a
disembodied hand named thing now the
series was adapted for TV by David Levy
who also created the short-lived Addams
Family animated show in 1973. aiding in
the show's longevity in the pop culture
landscape was its oh so catchy theme
song you know the one
that's just too much fun to do it came
from long time TV composer Vic Missy who
also did the famous Green Acres theme so
I guess he was good at that stuff now
with a strong audience score in the low
90s and a first season Tomato Meter
score at 100 this shows impact is clear
in how the franchise grew from this
point including two successful movies in
the 90s and of course the new Netflix
show Wednesday The Adams Family thrived
in syndication for years and is now
benefiting from the streaming age it
even has its own channel on Pluto TV I
mean come on top RT critic Jen Chaney
from New York Magazine said that this
series stands apart from the rest for a
number of reasons including quote it's
beatnik haunted house music it's elegant
costuming makeup and set design and the
quality of its Ensemble acting the show
aired for two seasons and 64 episodes
from 1964 to 1966. and binging this one
is easy all it takes is two snaps of
your fingers and somewhere around 27
hours of your time and be sure to look
out for the reunion TV film Halloween
with the new Adams Family which aired in
1977 and featured almost all of the
original cast
and this is for my sister Ophelia her
favorite perfume holiday Macabre
watch that oh hello Darlings that's a
Christmas present for your father don't
tell us it came from Santa Claus
and why not because Mr Thompson next
door said there is no such thing as
Santa Claus
what that neighbor of ours isn't very
neighborly telling the children that
getting caught up next as our under the
radar pick is the Disney show Stuck in
the Middle now this one features
Wednesday star Jenna Ortega and while
genziers might already know the show
older Generations may not be as familiar
Ortega was actually cast a star at age
14 but was already armed with recurring
roles on shows like Jane the Virgin and
Richie Rich in this series though set in
a fictional Massachusetts town she stars
as a young engineering Prodigy named
Harley Diaz as the middle of seven
children Harley navigates her way
through life in a big family by
creatively inventing and using various
gadgets she also commonly breaks a
fourth wall to help keep the audience
informed of what's Happening a move that
no doubt helped make her even more
endearing to audiences this show is
considered a hit for the Disney Channel
during its run and along with a couple
season renewals to get to three total
the show also picked up a handful of
Award nominations around the world
including three imagine award Noms and
one win for Jenna Ortega for best young
actor Stuck in the Middle launched in
February of 2016 and ended in July of
2018 after 57 episodes and six specials
at which point Ortega headed toward more
mainstream roles now benching this
series will take you 28 and a half hours
but the knowledge you'll gain about
building useful gadgets will be worth
every second of your time the whole
family has to be at the park by 11 for
something great
where's your travel mug not sure you got
a mug tracker better
I'm the middle kid so it's hand-me-down
City
I've Gotten Good at working with what
I've got I'm not bragging being creative
isn't a choice
it's survival enjoy your new travel
thumb
Hazelnut and dish soap weirdly it works
for our editor's pick this week they
have selected the Netflix series Warrior
none based on a manga style Canadian
comic book this fantasy drama is perfect
for any Wednesday fan who loves a badass
chick doing her thing Alba Baptista
stars as a 19 year old orphan who wakes
up in a morgue after being resurrected
by an ancient holy Relic now there she
discovers she's been chosen to join a
secret sect of demon hunting nuns the
series was created by Simon Berry who's
also behind shows like bad blood and
ghost Wars and this show marks the
English language debut for Portuguese
actress Baptista who also serves as
narrator Warrior none which is
beautifully shot around Spain has two
fresh seasons including a 100 Tomato
Meter score for season two with Baptiste
still leading the way and others like
Toya Turner is shotgun marry and support
the critics consensus praises the show's
committed performances and excellent
fight choreography and top RT critic
Heather Hogan from Auto straddle called
it quote excellent action adventure TV
with complex and nuanced women leads and
a bisexual Love Story anchoring the
whole thing in place for now you can
binge the first two seasons in around 18
hours and move over Sister Act movies
because this could very well change the
way you look at nuns moving forward
all of this
is my fault
the FBC gaining ground
I drill freed
I need to make this right
an angel walks the Earth
Adriel is real his Divine and Hell
belongs to him
time to come and get it wow my friends
we did it five shows you can bench to
help scratch that Wednesday itch and I'm
not talking about the kind of itch like
having a glass of wine on a Wednesday
night although that is also very
important too hopefully we have helped
you fill out your binging to-do list for
the next couple weeks and by the way if
you're looking to find more great shows
for binging purposes be sure to grab a
copy of our book ultimate binge guide it
is full of Specialists it features some
of the best shows of all time as always
don't forget to find us again for more
selections based on the shows and movies
that you love it is all right here on
Rotten Tomatoes binge guide and I'll see
you guys later peeps
foreign